increase
tell me when everyone's in
well Mr President welcome welcome it's
great to see you welcome to the White
House
this meeting it's been a long time
coming
we had to cancel this past summer
because I got covered
delighted to see you here
you know we're 200 years
200 years we were diplomatic relations
and uh
translated
and today we embark on the next Century
of a partnership
this meeting is a chance to reaffirm
that nothing is beyond our region we
work together
and thank you for participating in our
second Summit on Democracy earlier today
together we're working to protect human
rights and and ensure democracy delivers
for all of our people
is
together we said this we tend to stand
up for our democracies and what we value
and particularly the United Nations I
want to thank you and your government
for your weighing with your handling the
invasion of Ukraine unjustly by the
Russians
I think we have an enormous opportunity
to increase our economic interchange our
economic integration and everything from
clean energy to critical minerals to
technology to security
technology
about to sit on out on the next century
so let's have a good meeting because
there's a lot we can cooperate on yeah
thank you
thank you very much Mr President
did you uh
here we are in Washington it's not the
first time we've met we've already had a
chance to meet I think this is a third
or fourth time well actually it was the
G7 the summit of the Americas among
other occasions
but today we'll be able to specifically
talk about Argentina and the United
States
anymore
I think we have a great opportunity
ahead of us after 200 years of
diplomatic relations between us
in the last couple of years we've had to
deal with the terrible skirt which was
the covid-19 pandemic is
and I would like to thank you Mr
President for your support not just for
Argentina but also for our continent by
supplying vaccines which were very
useful in fighting the virus
foreign
more than once we've had an opportunity
to talk about the economic problems that
Argentina faces and which I inherited as
a president
IAL
the international context is not helping
companies
and I would also like to thank you for
that because your Administration has
also consistently supported us in the
context of international
financial institutions
foreign
we see the serious problem that the
Russian invasion of Ukraine has created
as you rightly pointed out we have
supported the U.N position in condemning
the invasions
the war has brought terrible damage to
the world economy
is
we need to work a lot together for that
war to end for no more human lives to be
lost and for the global economy to
recover as well
foreign
when the FAO says that over 300 million
people may be suffering from Hunger as a
result of the war we see how urgent
peace is and we need to do everything we
can and work together to make sure that
we can make this end
through
videos
I think that both the administration of
President Biden and our own see
democracy and human rights as Central
pillars for development
and we must continue to work in that
direction
foreign
I also believe that as countries we have
a great opportunity ahead of us
here
is
foreign
the world is demanding food it is
demanding energy and we have all of
those resources and we can produce them
in a
minute
is
you may recall my address at the
American Summit and I talked about the
importance of bringing together the
north the central part and the south of
the America so that we can all work on
producing and developing food for all of
humanity
and that is still one of my aspirations
which I hope we will be able to achieve
diplomatically
to share a concern with regard to
climate change
Argentina you may know is going through
the worst drought on record since 1929.
which has very much complicated our
economy
and this situation is something that we
are discussing with the financial
institutions
so we certainly uh do look forward to
your continued support the way we have
had it so far
and one last thing I would like to say
to you Mr President Washington
foreign
upon my arrival in Washington DC I saw
the flags at half mast
ERS Nashville
and I learned about the Nashville
tragedy
result
I would like to convey my solidarity and
sympathy to the families of the victims
foreign
but I would like to publicly State my
support for your initiative to regulate
the sale of firearms in the United
States
this idea which you are spearheading
represents a problem that the world
suffers
in my country some are suggesting that
arms should be sold freely in order to
for people to protect themselves
so I deeply value your initiative
absolutely
and you can count on me as an unreserved
partner
thank you thank you for expressing your
concerns
as a matter of fact as I speak now my
wife is down at that school meeting with
the families
to bring our sense of concern and so
it's it's very difficult losing a child
is hard
thank you
foreign
don't get hurt leaving please
[Music]
thank you
very much
[Music]
thank you
thanks so much
I don't know
foreign
Mr President welcome welcome it's great
to see you welcome to the White House
this meeting has been a long time coming
we had to cancel this past summer
because I got covered
delighted to see you here
you know we're 200 years
200 years we've had diplomatic relations
and uh
translated
and today we embark on the next Century
of a partnership
this meeting is a chance to reaffirm
that nothing is beyond our reach if we
work together
and thank you for participating in our
second Summit on Democracy earlier today
together we're working to protect human
rights and uh and ensure democracy
delivers for all of our people
and together we said this we tend to
stand up for uh democracies and what we
value and particularly the United
Nations I want to thank you and your
government for your weighing with your
handling the invasion of Ukraine
unjustly by the Russians
I think we have an enormous opportunity
to increase our economic interchange our
economic integration and everything from
clean energy to critical minerals to
technology the security
technology
we're about to sit on out on the next
century
let's have a good meeting because
there's a lot we can cooperate on yeah
thank you very much Mr President
is
here we are in Washington it's not the
first time we've met we've already had a
chance to meet I think this is the third
or fourth time we'll actually it was the
G7 the summit of the Americas among
other occasions
but today we'll be able to specifically
talk about Argentina and the United
States
okay
I think we have a great opportunity
ahead of us after 200 years of
diplomatic relations between us
in the last couple of years we've had to
deal with a terrible Scourge which was
the covid-19 pandemic is
and I would like to thank you Mr
President for your support not just for
Argentina but also for our continent by
supplying vaccines which were very
useful in fighting the virus
foreign
more than once we've had an opportunity
to talk about the economic problems that
Argentina faces and which I inherited as
a president in contact to International
the international context is not helping
companies
and I would also like to thank you for
that because your Administration has
also consistently supported us in the
context of international
financial institutions
foreign
we see the serious problem that the
Russian invasion of Ukraine has created
as you rightly pointed out we have
supported the U.N position in condemning
the
invasionally
the war has brought terrible damage to
the world economy
termina
is a
company
we need to work a lot together for that
war to end for no more human lives to be
lost and for the global economy to
recover as well
foreign
when the FAO says that over 300 million
people may be suffering from Hunger as a
result of the war we see how urgent
peace is and we need to do everything we
can and work together to make sure that
we can make this end
we are now
I think that both the administration of
President Biden and our own see
democracy and human rights as Central
pillars for development
and we must continue to work in that
direction
opportunity
I also believe that as countries we have
a great opportunity ahead of us
is
foreign
energy and we have all of those
resources and we can produce them in our
countries
Romania
you may recall my address at the America
Summit and I've talked about the
importance of bringing together the
north the central part and the south of
the America so that we can all work on
producing and developing food for all of
humanity
and that is still one of my aspirations
which I hope we'll be able to
achievement
we also share a concern with regard to
climate change
foreign
since 1929.
which has a very much complicated our
economy
and this situation is something that we
are discussing with the financial
institutions
so we certainly uh do look forward to
your continued support the way we have
had it so far
and one last thing I would like to say
to you Mr President
Washington
ameriato
upon my arrival in Washington DC I saw
the flags at half mast
maintenance
and I learned about the Nashville
tragedy
I would like to convey my solidarity and
sympathy to the families of the victims
yes
but I would like to publicly State my
support for your initiative to regulate
the sale of firearms in the United
States
this idea which you are spearheading
represents a problem that the world
suffers
Defenders
in my country some are suggesting that
arms should be sold freely in order to
for people to protect themselves
so I deeply value your initiative
and you can count on me as an unreserved
partner
thank you and thank you for expressing
your concerns sympathy as a matter of
fact as I speak now my wife is down at
that school a meeting with the families
to uh
bring our sense of concern
so it's it's very difficult losing a
child is hard
thank you
very much
don't get hurt leaving please
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you